في سقف زمني لاقرار مثل هذه التشريعات
الجديده التي يمكن ان يشعر بها المواطن
التونسي
نحن يعني في الدستور 25 جويليه 2022
صلاحيه التشريعيه
يعني تاتينا مشاريع القوانين من
من الوظيفه التنفيذيه عن طريق السيد رئيس
الجمهوريه او من خلال مبادرات يقوم بها
النواب يعني مبادرات نتاع مقترحات قوانين
يعني
وننتظر يعني هذه المشاريع التي سندرسها
وكذلك
حسب علمي هناك يعني العديد من النواب
الذين هم بسد اعداد مقترحات قوانين وسيتم
يعني عرضه على المجلس لمناقشتها والتصديق
عليها ان رؤوف في ذلك انها تمثل يعني
ناحيه ايجابيه بالنسبه للتشريعات
التي هي تسود البلاد وتسود الحياه
السياسيه والاقتصاديه
لكل تجاوزنا مرحله الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
للرئيس في تونس
طبعا طبعا منذ يوم
يعني وقع تجاوز الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
واحيلت الصلاحيه التشريعيه الى المجلس
التشريعي
ودليل على ذلك انه منذ يومارس
لم يصدر اي مرسوم عن رئيس الجمهوريه لان
صلاحيه التشريعيه التي
يعني احيلت له بمقتضى امر 22 سبتمبر 21
انتهت يوم 13 مارس 23 طيب لكن هناك من ما
زال يستخدم عباره برلمان شرعي فيما يعد
انه عدم اعتراف بسلطه البرلمان الجديد ولا
بالعمليه الانتخابيه وكانه تمهيد
للسيناريو اللي حدث في ليبيا اللي بتتنازع
فيه الشرعيات اولا هل هذا يجد صداه لدى
التونسيين
لا اولا بالذات لعن والحمد لله يعني
حافظنا على حريه التعبير وحريه الاجتماع
وحريه الاحتجاج
وكل يعني جهه سياسيه سواء يعني منظمه وحزب
يستطيعون العمل يعني بكل حريه في البلاد
ودليل على ذلك ان الاعلام يعني حر وكذلك
هناك يعني مظاهرات واحتجاجات
وسمح لها
بالتواجد
وبظهور الاعلامي وبالتالي يعني من له هذا
الراي بطبيعه الحال هو حر في
[موسيقى]
لكن ما يلاحظ ان هؤلاء لم يجدوا التجاوب
الشعبي الكافي بل على العكس من ذلك لا
زالت يعني
مسجد المصداقيه
واضحه بالنسبه لمسائل 25 جويليه والتي
تدابير 25 جويليه يوم الثلاثاء من اجراءات
ودليل على ذلك ان يعني الشعب ينتظر
اصلاحات حقيقيه وقد سئم السوره النمطيه
للبرلمان السابق وبالتالي فهو ينتظر انه
هذا البرلمان يحقق له طموحاتها ويحقق له
اماله ويحقق له اماله